so Wonder Brothers doesn't seem to have
a plan for DC let's see if we have one
so we get to do something we haven't
done in a long time
ah there's all three of us here like who
are you again I don't really remember I
know none of us do we asked for us in
the Q&A section so yes you asked where
they are they're here i dredge them out
of the basement where our children are
he needs to be answered
a little heat down there but Paul I got
Ryan we're all together and we are gonna
be talking about storylines from DC
Comics that we think could be used to
either be adapted straight into movies
for the DC EU or at least could be a
starting point into something we've all
got multiple ideas to toss out on this
and I'm gonna start with the guy that
and I'm terrified I'm about to say this
I'm gonna let Paul set the tone Paul do
you want to start us off absolutely and
I'm gonna side so if I'm my first
recommendation for DC if I'm looking at
the current market and I'm looking at
what's going on what's being successful
I look at the current tone sort of
politically in the United States but
also in Hollywood
Batwoman would be the I think the
perfect choice for DC right now if I was
DC I would actually just green like this
without a director without a script
without anyone and I would just tell the
public we're doing this we're gonna be
moving ahead with a Batwoman story
because we feel like we need more
empowered women in roles that young
women can look up to and I think that
the rebirth of Kate Kane as she's been
represented in the comics was
controversial but provocative and I
think all in good ways and I think she
can make an incredible film my only sort
of reluctance in recommending
this one is that she is a derivative
character and so there is sort of a
certain amount of you know she's not
really standing on her own she's just
kind of this you know putting on a
costume that a man wore first and but I
think that if you put that particular
critique aside I think that that
character would be a really solid choice
for DC I think it would be really
popular I think it would make them a ton
of money on the side but I think it
would be an extension of an already
proven property for Warner Brothers in
DC which is the back world first thought
on that you said and this isn't actually
necessarily a negative but I don't even
think it's it's not a question of her
being derivative I think she's almost
second-generation
derivative or twice removed because I
think when people think of female
equivalent of Batman
most people's go to his Batgirl sure
that was actually my girl is in the
public consciousness everybody kind of
knows her so if you say bat woman and
there's like a little bit of confusion
it's like an older version of Barbara
are we just sort of maturing her so
we're not calling her girl now she's a
woman and they you do kind of have to
make a distinction and if you make a bat
woman before you've introduced that girl
in whatever cohesive cinematic universe
they're trying to make if that is the
intention there might get a little bit
of a disconnect I don't think that is
such a problem I think trying to have
Batgirl and bat woman this sounds awful
like one too much and I I agree only by
technicality of the names as far as the
characters go I think there's more than
enough room for both of them because
they don't actually overlap a ton in
terms of their approach other characters
that history or their backgrounds I also
don't think you need I think that they
can be distinct into the city of Gotham
like I don't think that you actually
need background that woman bumping
shoulders and much the way I don't think
you need bad woman and Nightwing sort of
running into each other I would take one
or both of them out of Gotham and just
say that city is crowded enough with no
crime there's a transcenders in the
Batman you
one of the things I'm gonna talk about
what actually allowed for you so that
but I will come back to that so
come on bat well first of all I'm glad
you actually made the distinction in
case anyone watching doesn't know bat
woman is not Batgirl grown-up it is a
completely different character with a
different origin and with a different
mentality and she she is a woman who
going with the more recent budgetary
orders which actually I just lent or I
just gave back the volume that that Ryan
lent me so she grew up in the military
she enrolled in the military she was
getting ready to graduate this was still
during Don't Ask Don't Tell so when it
came out that she was a lesbian she had
to quit she's probably the most
prominent lesbian character since they
they kind of are still waffling on
really going all in on Wonder Woman so I
think I think bad woman still counts as
the mole she's not bad in her name which
give you a certain grade profile status
there's that and the other thing is I I
actually in regards to that relaunch I
really like how they dealt with the fact
that she adopts Batman's mantle because
from her point of view she views it much
in the same way that the uniform a
soldier puts on you put it on because
it's a call to arms and you are taking
this uniform to symbolize that you are
fighting for the same cause right not
because like I don't want to do what
they did like it is a symbolic gesture
and the way in the moment that they have
that has her decide like that is the
cause I'm going to now take his just a
great moment but I think I think she
would be a very good pick unfortunately
I think you are right in terms of Brian
in terms of logistical II figuring out
timing for where to fit her in in terms
of the public not getting confused gets
wonky but in isolation yes please cuz if
nothing else I love her look amazing
yeah you know I like the idea I'm
worried and I again I hear myself saying
this and it sounds terrible and I don't
agree with them but I bump into the idea
of that woman bad girl
Robin Nightwing Batman this just it's
crowded in the same family yeah if we
can sidestep that if we can ignore that
if the movie is just good if they just
did it but nobody cares yeah Ryan what
you got for your first one
I was thinking outside
the box and I decided for my first one
I'm going to talk about a Batman movie
oh wow we really didn't far afield but
man you know you know Warner Brothers
seems really reluctant to put Batman in
things I know now they are working on
the Batman written and directed by Matt
Reeves or at least directed there might
be other screenwriters involved this is
their plan there they're jamming this
and we're fine nobody really knows what
this is if it's going to be a one stain
alone movie is it gonna be separate from
the continuity i from what I've heard
Warner Brothers really wants members to
do a trilogy and basically give him the
keys to the character for the next half
a decade whether or not he wants to do
that I don't know yeah so whatever I
think he will make an interesting Batman
movie but right now I'm not interested
in it I'm not interested in just another
bad movie between The Dark Knight and
Lego Batman I feel like I've gotten
these two extremes between this kara
I've seen so many flavors of this
character that have tried to stretch out
to two and a half hour movies and I'm
worried that with members are just gonna
try and make it more ultra realistic and
more epic at the same time they're gonna
go bigger and bigger
we're brothers won't be able to help
themselves that's just they're just
gonna keep trying that and I would
rather them go smaller
okay and what what is smaller look like
well for me so small that you can
actually put three stories into one
movie I want a Batman in follow G movie
oh I've used this DNA from you before so
same cast same actor plays Batman in
three different stories same actress
playing Alfred Gordon whoever you need
but three different stories about 40
minutes in length something about their
three different writers and director
teams and everything three different
styles so you can have one that is a
proper whodunit mystery and you can
actually focus on the world's greatest
detective you can do one maybe
jet-setting international James Bond
type of Batman story you can do one sort
of gritty horriffic type of scary one or
one that is more lighthearted a little
bit sillier more reflective on the
southwest
you can have one like that almost treats
Batman almost as like I was a side
character or like an afterthought it
focuses on either a cop
or villain or something like that you
get that perspective but ultimately
three different stories three different
get three different auteur directors
have them do their stamp on the Batman
mythos this could be how you get
somebody like a Martin Scorsese and said
if you were given basically the chance
to do like a one-hour TV episode like
without commercials what would you do
with this character and you find some
kind of threat to package them all
together you bring that legends of the
Dark Knight or legends of Batman or
something like that and this could just
be a vehicle if this could be the
franchise you just get a series of these
where you get different filmmakers
coming in doing short Batman stories and
I think it's a tough sell but here's the
main thing that I like about it at this
point there are so many different
iterations of Batman but Warner Brothers
keeps putting ones up on the screen and
insisting like and this is the version
of Batman's like can we just accept
there is no definitive D version of
Batman and doing an approach like that
is a good way around that where you're
not trying to claim the definitive
you're allowing for it look Batman is
pretty malleable here's the buffet and I
think if they trust the character they
trust the brand of Batman which they
always seem to be hanging on that then I
think he is the one care for where they
can experiment with safely and I think
Lego Batman kind of testifies to that I
think this ooh I love that idea
but I think the part of me that loves
that idea is the adult in me that wants
to see these different versions of the
character I think it would be it well
not impossible but I think in terms of
the branding I think the toys would
probably be tricky trickier for that
particular version and the only reason I
bring that up is that that is a big
piece
I don't think Warner Brothers has been
making these with toys in mind lately to
be completely blunt I mean if they
weren't the Nolan Batman's took over
room if they were making these with kids
in mind um
they won't first of all they wouldn't
have released Batman V Superman even the
Saint was in and they definitely would
not have allowed an r-rated cut to be
made available on blu-ray slightly it's
maybe I'm looking at
version of Warner players I think more I
think the market is probably more
towards older toy collectors than it is
the kids who play with them I love this
idea though and I think there's a lot I
also think it's particularly well poised
for things like streaming and for just
sort of releasing online in general
because we have shorter attention spans
I think if you sort of think about sorry
we're already talking about it
hey Finn's worthy TV like we want the
the sort of little chunks that little
bite-sized pieces and that would fit you
get ultimate customer they're just in
different orders or something like that
yeah plus everybody who thinks the
market is oversaturated with Batman
here's three take that well okay so that
cat so I didn't know when I was gonna
bring this one up but you know what
let's clear this whole thing off the
deck it let me get put my Batman idea
out there so that we can then move off
about it so this will be so I love it
yeah so I have some notes Batman yes so
this will be something to do actually
after you've had a number of your
independent films like say a bat woman a
bad girl a Nightwing whatever but this
would be your crossover story to bring
them all together and that would be no
man's land mm-hmm which I think actually
is not only a way to bring all the
heroes together but it will allow Warner
Brothers to do what they also want to do
but can't find a way to do it properly
which is to load it up with villains as
well yeah because there was rumor for a
while that and this was before Ben
Affleck wasn't gonna direct the Batman
anymore that they were gonna take heavy
influence from the Arkham Asylum video
game would you of course is probably
best known for the fact that it said in
Arkham Asylum which means you can just
load every villain into it right but
it's also pretty contrived it works in
the game cuz you then get to be Batman
so you forgive the narrative contrivance
but for a film that's really contrived
but when you have this there's been an
earthquake and Gotham is now this this
broken up city that's now a bit
completely sectioned off because it's
such a mess and the criminals are just
dividing territory all over the place it
gives you but it gives the heroes a
reason to both interact but also have
their own thing going
as you know maybe Nightwing's trying to
deal with scarecrow over here and that
woman is trying to handle what Clayface
is up to and you've got all that and you
can have the integration now the only
reluctance I have on this is there are
so many many pieces and so many moving
pieces you might have to do it as two
parts which I don't love having to say
because I don't like breaking a story
into two parts but I think you might
have to in this case I think my first
thought was that would be a good way to
do a multi-part Batman you like movie
story or something like that and I I
think breaking the movie up and do
separate parts it just it really depends
on if there's a natural break for it
yeah my problem like with the last two
Harry Potter movies that adapted the
seventh book was that I didn't feel like
there was a natural break and just like
the narrative didn't support that so you
had the seventh movie which told part of
the story without an ending and then the
eighth movie was just like a two-hour
long climax of the previous story it
just felt to me it felt very disjointed
and I didn't like those experiences
watching those movies suddenly but I
think this works I think though you if
you're crafting the story you can find a
finite place to build the ending of the
first if again if we decide to do a
party you can the way the the Lord of
the Rings movies did they had to I felt
like there was a map breaking well and
there's an easy enough way to do it if
you put your like I say you'll have a
ton of villains but if you put a primary
here's the guy we're dealing with now in
the first movie you deal with him but
then also set up at the end oh but these
other three guys during horses now we
deal with that so you might dealt with
the immediate now you deal with the
bigger threat it's like Star Wars we
blew up the the the Death Star but now
we have to defeat the Empire yep I think
that that I think it's a fantastic I
didn't I think gives you a lot of
latitude for bringing in a lot of these
sort of disparate characters I also
thinks that I think it gives you an
opportunity to redraw Gotham if you want
it which is you know you can sort of
relaunch some characters you can put
different people into costumes you can
play you know you can seed so much you
can see - Renee Montoya if you want to
set mark to take over as the question
later I'm a business and I I think it it
would help to have some established
Batman
properties out there before you do this
yeah but I think you can also do that as
a way of introducing that could be the
you know the catalyst that invents
that's where Kate Cain says we do need
somebody to stay on that's when she
decides to put on the costume to be bad
woman or something like that or the same
thing for a fat girl or somebody else
from his room you know as real or
something like that you can that could
also be the origin story took one of the
people in the Batman family up there
actually Azrael will be interesting to
throw in there to have especially if
you've already done and yeah I wouldn't
want to do him in his own movie but know
if you've already done a Batgirl and a
bat woman things like that people who
took up the mantle and did it right have
somebody who is inspired and then just
does it wrong
and he becomes a wild card in this other
mess they're dealing with so Paul back
to you all right so one of the
properties I am most excited about
actually he's in it so I can't avoid him
but it's super sense and I want this so
badly I can taste it and the the premise
behind this if you if you're not
familiar with the comics is basically
that Damian Wayne and John Kent are
little boys these being the children of
Batman and Superman respectively right
and they are buddies and they fight
crime together and also Krypto the
Superdog is there and it's streaky the
super cat there now and there's forget
it I'm walking away and then the thing
is is that there's a couple different
approaches you could take with us and
the first would be animated which I
think would fit it pretty well but it
would have to be big it would have to be
like Pixar level quality bit kind of a
superhero country exactly and orly
Incredibles sort of feel to it and I
think it could be fantastic and fun in
over-the-top and having them solve
crimes like you know it could be like
cat up a tree type of stuff right but
the cat is actually this evil you don't
mine scientist and wants them up the
tree and the trees actually a special
trap and who knows it's so like right
and so and and like indie scene needs
fun so badly like it needs to have a
good time and these characters would be
nothing but that the idea of these boys
out there and like fighting crime doing
it earnestly making mistakes I think you
get if you can get the dichotomy that we
want from Batman and Superman which is
like you know you have Damian Wayne
who's like an assassin you have kind of
a dick right here if you have this young
man who's been raised by you know Lois
and Superman and like who wants he's
literally a Boy Scout and and like the
two of them like arguing of like how to
deal with problems and then getting in
over their head and having like Bruce or
Clark or both of them having to show up
and fix or take care of like whatever it
is the missus made worse by trying to
save let it anyway well that's your act
to but then for whatever reason they
can't come and deal with the thing and
they actually have to come together and
write in act 3 and so anyway I would buy
those tickets now and I want the poster
so just gonna say why do I have a
feeling you're gonna Commission that the
next time you're out of con super Sons
okay yeah not nice I like it okay my
next one I and I wasn't going to go with
it but again through matically it sort
of backs up though because it's another
it's a group of younger heroes but I
didn't go with the Teen Titans actually
going with the Legion of super-heroes oh
and for anybody watching it if you have
not really familiar the Legion of
super-heroes cartoons and animation they
bumped up in Smallville way and now
Supergirl all I believe yeah
but the premise is basically they're
from the 30th century now I guess the
31st century 1000 years in the future
maybe whatever whenever you're reading
the kind of a thousand you guys Rosen
yeah you've got a United Federation of
Planets not unlike Star Trek but a lot
more combative
sort of but all these different plants
they all have different representatives
and us
there's just a group of younger people
they could be younger kids or teenagers
or early 20s they kind of always kind of
grow up and everything but it's
essentially young people and from
different planets they all have
different powers that are unique to
their home planet or some of them are
mutants or something like that but they
come together and they are inspired by
the legend of Superboy or you can say
Superman it doesn't matter they
originally it's Superboy and they've
used Superboy is like a mythology figure
like the way we look at stories about
Hercules
ya know classical mythology except
because they have it time travel device
because it's a thousand years in the
future they can actually go back and
meet Superboy and meet their Idol and he
can go to the future and interact with
them now for the premises of this you
can have Superboy or Superman be a
character in the story but you don't
need to essentially all you need to know
and this is why I think it's it might be
a little bit easier than the Teen Titans
because the Teen Titans kind of have to
brush up against their older figures
whether there's a side kids and they're
just the next generation they're kind of
living in the shadow of the Justice
League or something like that so you
kind of have to acknowledge that
presence with the Legion there's enough
of a remove that you just have to know a
long long time ago there was Superman or
Superboy and maybe a Justice League but
you maybe don't have to mention them but
you've got it I think it plays to hard
space sci-fi like hit like Star Trek or
silly you're psychic like guardians of
the galaxy but it's essentially a
younger group of kids over here oh so
you can play into things like The Maze
Runner trilogy or divergent like things
like that so those type of properties
those type of fan bases those type of
actors when I give those kids and kind
of bring them in something that is
unique self-contained all you need to
know is that there is a Superboy
from this universe but you not
handcuffed to what the Justice League
does or something like that now my first
question is have you gone so far in this
concept as to figure out your roster
because when you talk to Legion there's
a lot of option there's 50 people I mean
this is a huge thing they're they like
x-men big it's not quite but a little
bit I would and these to the at the
start I would be living out I would tend
to focus on the three kids who are
originated which is cosmic boy Lightning
Lad
Saturn girl but also I would be tempted
to throw Brainiac 5 in there tonight
I put me to believe it's fun to have
Brainiac 5 you think about Brainiac as
one of Superman's primary villains and
here is a descendant of him who's a good
guy and ends up becoming super girl's
girl boyfriend so arm fall off boy yay
then thrown an easter egg just some you
know like a montage fight or wherever
where you get the tryouts and it's got
takes his arm off he's like this is my
power I can take my arm all you need is
them going down a hallway and like
there's a door there's a door to a room
and oh it over it says tryout so you
just see this guy played like revolution
and everything I'm like dad get like you
know get my Chemical Romance to do I
just haven't seen arm fall foot just
pulls his arm off instead of beating the
bad guy but yeah like other like you
would I don't know if you really know
this property you would love it you love
them oh my favorite character he's one
of the legions of substitute heroes his
name is chlorophyll kid his power is to
speed up or slow down the growth of
plants he can't control them like a
poison ivy tech right he can just make
them grow really fat or not or really
slow if you need that so it's a lot of
them have crazy SEPA cific tower
missions it just brings a pocketful
seeds like I don't think before I would
Teen Titans I would try something like
the Legion of super-heroes because it
gives you a sci-fi Star Trek superhero
base that's a little bit airy pod or a
little bit divergent things like that
but it also has a finger in the realm of
the DC superheroes essentially now we've
done a couple of light ones in a row I'm
gonna take it upon myself to go dark um
and this this via this would be a later
this would be I mean obviously it's
centers on one characters more
specifically but this is no
but this will be big enough to probably
need to be a Justice League story okay
blackest night which is a Green Lantern
story and it incorporates because the we
knew about the Green Lantern's and the
Green Lantern power ins the Green
Lantern's are basically space cops for a
while we knew about the yellow rings
which feed on fear and that's the polar
opposite but then we find out there is a
whole spectrum of rings including the
black Lantern's that basically just
harness death and and you have basically
the rise of the black Lantern's and then
trying to stop that and there's a couple
of things I mean obviously it's a very
large-scale story clearly and it is one
that definitely justifies including
whoever they have introduced in the
movies up to that point if they keep the
twist that Black Lantern rings can not
only resurrect dead characters as black
Lantern's ie
evil zombie versions of themselves but
can also take over people who have died
and come back to life well you know what
Warner Brothers can finally have that
evil Superman they kept hinting at and
never got to do they can have him for a
hot minute and they had him welcome but
they can have him for a hot minute and
then be done with it and finally feel
like they got it out of their system and
leave it the hell alone
and I just and the thing is I don't feel
that it is necessary to stick to a lot
of specifics of this story I don't think
you need to introduce specifically the
concept of necron I don't think you need
to get into the the way the parallax
entity and all these things actually
work I think you just you boil it down
to the basics the spectrum of colors the
color the colors of the Rings correspond
to different emotions I do think you
keep who each well who most of the Rings
tie themselves to like it is perfect
that the orange avarice ring goes to Lex
Luthor it is perfect that the yellow
fear ring goes to scarecrow I think you
do keep some of those but like we don't
need the specifics on that cron we don't
need the specifics of which superheroes
got resurrected as black Landers but I
think the concept is big enough to
justify that big a movie but it's also
malleable enough as a broad-stroke to
tweak it so that we don't have
literally retell the story the narrative
of the comic book told sofort any we're
getting a Green Lantern core movie yes I
don't think you can introduce the
Lantern Corps in a blackest night film I
think you have to lay that groundwork in
a separate movie yeah probably that was
gonna be my question yet what
prerequisites do we need the aliens you
you need to do you need to do a Green
Lantern movie first and you need a Green
Lantern people like and the sorry but
beyond that so here's my here's my fear
with this is that while DC is getting
this project off the ground
Marvel is going to just do a Marvel
Zombies movie and it is going to be fun
and ridiculous and over-the-top and
we're gonna see four okay just just like
hold on hold on just popping the heads
of like 6,000 zombies in a row with his
hammer right and I'm not saying that
Marvel Zombies is a better property but
what I am saying is that Marvel is gonna
do a better job with this and and then
DC is gonna look at it and go and I
think it's gonna get killed in
pre-production before it even gets off
the ground so that's my thought here's
what I was like if Marvel's makes a
Marvel zombie movie first yes you're
right but however I have said this
before and I will say it again I want
Kevin Feige to walk through the offices
of the junior executives working at
Marvel if there is anyone with a stack
of Marvel Zombies trades on his desk
fire him right now I do not want Marvel
Zombies in a movie ever yeah it's gonna
make them so much money ever no no and
it's fine if you like Marvel Zombies
fine keep a lot of the movies no I like
blackest night I don't like that story a
lot it's steeped in history with
characters and lore that so far to date
has not been established by the DC movie
universe so either
you need to wait five or six years
before you do blackest night and you
need to like lay a lot of crunk or you
have to tweak the story a lot and it
sounds like you're okay with tweaking
the story a lot accessible for this and
I'm fine if the movie is good it's good
it you'll have to make a lot of changes
and I'm fine with that I mean I I would
encourage that anyway and actually
that's that's the case for all three
that I'm proposing was the case for
no-man's land - is like these are
premises I want to see movies up I don't
want to see a literal translation of the
narrative that was already told off this
premise I want them to take what's the
starting concept great let's figure out
our version of that because enemy I
don't mean to keep comparing them
tomorrow but Marvel does is very
correctly that's why Civil War works
they didn't literally retell the story
of Civil War because the story of Civil
War from the comics actually isn't that
good but they took the starting premise
and made a really good movie out of it
that DC needs a consistent presence from
the lanterns in the DC you and or the DC
Cinematic Universe
whatever the heck they're gonna call it
a kiddy we decide what they call and I
think that that has been lacking I think
that how Jordan or whatever Green
Lantern is that you gravitate to has
been sorely missed in in that universe
in that whole sort of space opera kind
of space cop portion of it that he
brings that the lanterns bring I think
that if DC can start to do that I think
you can then have room for telling those
big stories like a snake fair enough I
mean that this one is one that would
have to be sat on for a little while but
let's dip ball you got a last one for us
um I've got a couple of others but okay
yeah I've got more than one more okay
alright so I've only got one more so I'm
kind of know know will go however long
we go all right so this one is a little
bit of a reach oh yeah alright from you
alright so once upon a time Hal Jordan
speaking of the Green Lantern's had an
enemy called igneous man igneous man's
powers basically are he can get super
hot and he can deal with radiation but
his backstory is is that he's
essentially
he's this alien who's a bounty hunter
who really really loves his job you know
I really like this guy here's what I
would do with him is I would use him as
this bounty hunter for hire who
basically gets hired by someone like an
Amanda Waller who sort of I know that
we're leaning towards Suicide Squad sort
of things but basically she pulls him
out and gives him these impossible sort
of people to capture and for him the
goal is not he he sort of loves the game
of catching these people of catching
these sort of impossible targets right
and so it would be sort of like a you
know sort of a spy kind of Detective
action sort of thing and maybe his
powers aren't always present all the
time but at the end of it anyway so I
have this sort of sort of story worked
out with him where he you know he ends
up catching whoever it is and he has an
insanely high cost like to get him to do
stuff that's like fifty million dollars
or something like that and when he gets
his payment they you know it gets backed
up to his hideout or his cave or he
steeps and his radioactive stew and he
just he sets all the money on fire do
you remember the first word you said
when this episode began the first word
Lobo he's a bounty hunter honey and he's
not a figment of your dream you just
made up I still every blue moon I hear
talk about Justice League dark yeah and
this idea of bringing all of these DC
horror characters together for
and every time I hear about it I hate
the idea yeah because I'm gonna do the
same thing they did with Justice League
which is they're gonna rush something
and it's gonna be a mess the thing is I
like all these characters and instead of
throwing them together on one team when
they don't have to be a team cuz they're
they're not team players instead of
mixing them give them legitimate solo
movies first I want to see a new
swampthing movie yeah has had two movies
head room not good no but yeah the
sophistica the sophistication of telling
these type of movies has increased the
budgets and the special effects of it
Chris you could do a wonderful Swamp
Thing movie today sure yes I also think
you could do Deadman which I still think
would be a father for a wonderful TV
series more than a movie because it's
basically supernatural quantum leap but
you could do at your game the demon or
something like that you could do some of
these other horror characters or
something but I would just like don't
don't try to throw all of these together
in some big cluster as Justice League
dark don't brand it that way cuz I
seriously I don't think whatever others
likes the name Justice League right now
they might think that's a toxic brand
but just do a Swamp Thing movie you can
you can even reintroduce John
Constantine that way you could have it
Matt Ryan or we could cast him but
somebody brand-new but he could be sort
of a Samuel Jackson type of character
that make theory who starts you pepper
through all of these different
supernatural horror movie plots and
maybe if you want to and there's no
urgency to do this if you want to you
can bring them all together as a team or
an ensemble thing you throw this a year
saying that we could put them all
together in a team and make a bigger
movie that would make tons of money and
let's do it this year so yeah I'm gonna
argue with you on on one point I cuz I
agree if you're gonna go in this
direction give swampthing his own movie
because either version of Swamp Thing
you do whether you do the original
version or Alan Moore's
reinvention of him either one totally
supports its own movie mm-hmm
I will grant you know some of these
characters better than I do but I kind
wander do you get unless you're doing an
origin movie which I think we're all
kind of sick of mm-hmm is there a movie
to be told with the demon with dead man
with evens atonic Len like you say
they're not team players I agree with
that but I also think that like I saw
the Justice League dark animated film
which is one of the better things
they've done and if you establish a
baseline for how these characters work
that they're not T plays but they do
bounce off each other really well when
you throw them in a team dynamic and
while I would still say do swampthing
first and even use that to see
Constantine I would argue I'm not sure
most of these other characters hold a
movie on their own so here's my end and
maybe this is the distinction they don't
necessarily have to be superhero movies
they don't have to have that flavor I
think you can do the spectre as a horror
crime as a crime horror movie a murder
detective detective comes back with the
supernatural ghosty powers and exacts
revenge
that could be an r-rated just terrifying
like like crime thriller technical bunny
and they ready Kruger is the good guy
yeah essentially yeah don't make them
necessarily superhero movies okay make
them horror movies because that's where
these characters were established I do
think you could do the demon Etrigan as
a fantasy adventure thing about this
cursed guy who says this Wyman becomes a
demon character he's sort of a a Hulk
who's a little bit more manageable and a
little bit has ever work with things
like guy and well you say like he's he's
a Hulk who can come up with a who can
scheme right actually more manageable
maybe you think it is maybe the hope of
Loki's personality yeah honestly okay
fine you put it that way I'll buy that
ticket yeah so and then after you've
done the legwork do a couple of these
and if the story presents itself you can
bring them together and do it like in a
way that where Constantine and where
it's actually like the thing about the
Avengers or about the Justice League is
essentially you've got people who all
have the same agenda and they're all
coming together to fight crime or to
save the day from the the thing about
all these different work
they don't all want the same thing yeah
so you need a kind of a very special
particular kind of crisis to bring them
together for Constantine the meeting
that needs a lie to them and manipulate
them in order to get them to work
together to achieve some ends and some
of them might have to be like forced
against their will you might have to put
a branding spell to get them to
cooperate and that leads to more
conflict and more strife so that so
alright so this is the last one that I
have if you guys have more we can do
some more but oh god Paul's got ideas I
saw that in his eyes okay but this is
the this is the last one that I'm gonna
throw my never good so I'm gonna say I'd
be very curious to see especially Ryan's
face on this identity crisis now like
what I said with the other two I propose
I'm not saying do the plot again I'm
saying take the premise again okay
do a locked door mystery that hinges on
the fact that these people maintain
super secret identities because this is
very literally something in that Marvel
could not do because Marvel with their
movies aren't doing secret identities
spider-man kind of has one but they at
the end of homecoming the person that it
is most important that it keep it from
finds out so that's even half neutered
even characters like Ant Man maybe he's
not known to the public but all the
other superheroes know who he is they're
not doing secret identities in the MCU
they are doing them more at least so far
with the DC movies and if they continue
to lean into that embrace that element
of superheroes that Marvel just isn't
doing it allows you to do a mystery
story based on the fact that these
people are living these double lives
some of them know who each other are
some of them don't who knows everything
and like who would have the information
necessary to pull off this murder that
happened now scrap the specifics through
all the specifics scrap the motivation
the backstory all of that but start with
that kernel of a locked door mystery
with superheroes where the fact that not
all of them on one of one of these kids
yes not all and that not all of them
know who each of them are is a big
factor in how this plays out in the
level of
they haven't each other in trying to
figure it out okay so I think that
that's brilliant
I think the problem with it is they're
the DC Cinematic Universe is not big
enough yet
in order to to do this I don't think
they're I don't I think we need honestly
a Marvel level of characters in order
for us to have a story sufficiently
large enough to carry that that would be
my argument and I would have like what
five once he hears that I ways I would
say depending on how many characters
they see with the Batman movie that
might give us enough now it is dependent
on a movie that hasn't been made yet I
will grant but I would imagine for how
much other bat related stuff they've
already said they want to do for how
much stuff there at least gonna seed or
at least indicate this character does
exist in this universe
I think after one two at the most Batman
related movies will have enough to do
this like with that explanation that is
just sort of the stripped down bare
bones idea of identity crisis without
any of the very divide the divisive and
controversial elements of the the story
as it was committed I do like that idea
I'm sort of with all that I do think you
need a pretty big cast this is one of
those things though where I I wonder if
the public the general public doesn't
get enough credit or it's too much
because I'm all men we're going how do
you do all of these characters need
their own origin stories do we need to
have given all these people before we
got together
couldn't you just create a new movie and
say this is the Justice League it's the
flash document Green Lantern like
elongated mainland people who haven't we
haven't seen before is that really gonna
throw people off and say I haven't seen
it I haven't seen the Green Lantern
movie or the elongated man movie so I
don't know what that is but because I
heard that complain about the Justice
League movie but I don't know if he was
just a fault in that movie and I think
it was a fault on that move because did
we get an origin story for every member
of the guardians of the galaxy no no we
left directly into the team writing
right so I think you could probably get
way with as long as you've got a league
with seven or eight people or something
like that and and you establish I know I
think the victim I think it's got to be
wild can I can I float a controversial
choice but I would this would be
completely predicated on again changing
the motivations for the reason this
person gets killed but if you want to
plant a flag in this Lois Lane that was
my first thought I thought instead of
doing the along it really likes him
nobody knows that enough sorry yeah
nobody knows them enough he doesn't have
the families
so I was thinking Lois Lane or iris West
because at least with the flash TV show
a lot of people have heard that name
they kind of know and you just say the
flash has a wife or a girlfriend yeah
fiance she was also murdered in the
comics a long time ago but she got
better like you do in comics but my one
reluctance was actually killing Lois
Lane is I I do think there's a degree in
which that breaks Superman and that
fundamentally alters who he is
they've already broken him anyways a
game like injustice or something like
that in the comics related to that where
the instigating incident is a major bomb
in metropolis and Lois Lane kills and it
turns Superman into this fascist monster
well I would say at this point that's so
established that going the opposite way
would be a really good way to undercut
that so what if wanting to honor her
memory becomes a thing that tethers him
even stronger than her actual presence
did maybe I could work so Paul you had
that gleam in your eye that scares the
crap out of me I know you got at least
one more oh alright so you've got a
couple maybe we burn through them okay
alright so this aren't film it's TV is
that okay okay then yes we're dead
that's fine but we're gonna we're gonna
rapid fire them okay quick alright so um
I don't know why this hasn't been done
yet but I would propose Batgirl as a
television series and and what I would
do is I would have it be
Barbara Gordon I would not have her go
through the wheelchair thing I would
just have her sort of emerge into this
role like watching what her dad's doing
seeing Batman out doing his job and
being spike inspired by it deciding to
go out crazily to fight crime on our own
but with some background training and
whatnot
I would age up or down depending on
which property you're talking about
Selina Kyle so either from Gotham up and
from the comic books down and sorry
about man I know you're proposing to her
but anyway yeah it is in the comics and
so what I would do is I would I would
make it kind of like a buddy sort of
show with Selina Kyle and Barbara we're
on the back yeah and and they could like
they could be friends they could hang
out you know there are lots of different
there are lots of different ways you
could take it they could not know about
each other they couldn't know about each
other I think it's more fun if they do
know and that instead of her being
Batman's foil she's kind of Batgirl soil
but that there's this like you don't
have to have the sexual tension between
them or you can if that's the direction
you want to go but it's I think that
those two characters would play really
nicely together
want to show anything it can be fun and
light so Batgirl I think that lends
itself to a weekly show as well because
I think Batgirl tends to lean more into
the detective aspects that have become
more and more vestigial to Batman over
time and if you're doing detective
hunting stories that works on a weekly
schedule because that's why the aspect
of Batman doesn't make the movies
because they want the big action set
pieces and his detective angle doesn't
work for that works for macro works
weekly show what else he got Skeets and
booster and so the now listen Booster
Gold is probably one of the most where
you download this episode you're even
still here the entirety of what we did
so Booster Gold and his robots key no
that's not what I said Skeets and
booster and so basically the premise of
this show would be that sort of think of
it like Inspector Gadget
it would be a kind of a comedy we're
booster is a complete disaster
and it's really Skeets who has to sort
of pull his butt out of whatever says so
Skeets his brains and penny rolled into
one yes and he's kind of like Skeets is
actually a legitimate hero in this kind
of saving the day from Booster who's
they're trying to save but he's kind of
he's messing things up and everything in
boosters maybe he also seems he's doing
your oh absolutely
long into everything and you know he's
God is you know branding sort of stuff
and like his whole corporate identity
that he has associated with him and and
Skeets is basically behind him with the
dustpan kind of like you know pulling
the strings moving the stuff calling the
people fixing you know it's actually
Jeeves and Wooster and actually be
another good comparison
you know Paul I don't know what I hate
more the fact that you come up with
these ideas but the fact that you make
me kind of want to see it happen it's
our earth it's Pete's in mr. okay the
last thing right all right and pull it
back from that good luck um I mentioned
a little bit ago that I do think Warner
Brothers is nervous about the braining
of Justice League yeah and they need
something else I think what they can do
because the audience we've shown that we
like seeing our heroes work together we
like seeing these team ups and
everything like that but instead of
throwing five or six people together
look at what's fair Ragnarok did you get
the same kind of energy in the same by
just seeing two working together well DC
Comics has a property that is known for
Team ups The Brave and the bold and
historically it was a Batman thing but
not always but you can basically just do
it as then that is their new brand of
putting two of their established heroes
or one established and one brand new
together and you throw them together and
just a just an adventure that you kind
of have steps so you can have a Superman
and Wonder Woman team up movie this way
that doesn't have to be Man of Steel 2
or 1 or 1 2 or something like that
it's the brave the bold the Superman and
Wonder with them the brave the bold
Batman and Plastic Man
the brave the bold the flash and Booster
Gold
you know you introduced Booster Gold
that way or something like that our
Batman Booster Gold you have yes I'll
put up with this nonsense and realize
that you can do like weird things you
could do like the flash and Etrigan the
demon you could do Green Lantern and
Hawkman Wonder Woman and doctor faint
like this could just be a thing where
you throw in characters that you would
haven't seen together and everything it
just must be the team-up they because
you give the excitement of bringing two
characters maybe they're foils for each
other maybe they're not necessarily the
two that you would automatically put
together and you see them working
together so you get fandoms from both
properties you know you might get people
like I am NOT gonna watch another
Superman movie you know Man of Steel was
terrible something like that but I loved
Wonder Woman oh there's a new movie
that's gonna have this Wonder Woman and
that sir yeah okay I'll go just because
I really loved Wonder Woman that much
and that's how you bring somebody to has
no intention of seeing another Superman
movie to see a good Superman with me so
I yeah I like that actually I like that
a lot alright so it's kind of like we're
pitbull and flow right up we'll do a
song together alright we're gonna wrap
it up right there yeah under everything
I said mashups so guys thanks so much
for showing up these guys do their own
stuff there's gonna be links for all
this down below he writes comics they do
a webcomic together he does podcasts I
have a Twitter and an email and a
patreon links for all this crap is down
below so thanks so much for joining me
guys that has been too long
this was fun ish they sent you the six
months thanks for trying Paul so until
next time this council is adjourned
lowball
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]